[Music]  intelligence  stamina  courage and heart my business is dogs  he's under sized is trouble  [Music]  well good afternoon is untrainable  what does he bring to the breed the  heart of a survivor  he outran every single one of them he's  not a sled dog he's a lead dog  what we have in our children is an  epidemic the death sentence they found a  cure  round trip is 600 miles you see that  storm in the horizon only one man and  one dog can make that run he's 12 years  old he's too old he'll never make that  distance that when warned you pumped  my guess yes we don't find him until the  thought  all right Togo time for us to find out  who we are  I always thought he lived for the sled  when all along  what he lived for  was me  Hey  [Music]  you